Greetings to my 3BN family at home and
welcome to another 3BN today Bible Q&A.
We've got another great program. I'm
going to be your host today and you know
we've got some questions and we're going
to be finding those answers in the word
of God
>> of which our panelists will be sharing
those answers. Let me introduce you to
our panel right away. Next to me is
Sister Shelley Quinn. Welcome, sister.
>> I'm so pleased to be here. This is one
of my favorite programs to do and I want
to thank each of you for sending in your
questions.
>> Amen. Amen. And next to her, got my
brother, Pastor James Rafferty. Welcome,
sir.
>> Good to be here, Ricky. Uh, glad to join
you and my sister in Christ, Shelley
Quinn. Looking forward to the questions,
looking forward to the answers.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, before we get into the
word, why don't we start off with a word
of prayer? We need to ask God for
guidance and helping us understand his
word. Let's pray.
Father in heaven, as we've come to study
your word together, we recognize that we
can't understand it
>> unless we have a measure of your Holy
Spirit. So, we're asking that you would
please give us your Holy Spirit. Also,
we praise you for your son, Jesus, who
you sent down to die for us. We ask that
his blood will cover us and cleanse us
from all unrighteousness.
And father, we look forward to your soon
coming. Help us to remain faithful to
you. We ask this in Jesus name. Amen.
>> Amen.
>> All right. Well, Pastor Daniel, I've got
your first question, but let me remind
our viewers at home how they can
participate. You can participate with
3ABN Bible study, Bible Q&A. One of
three ways. You can send us your
questions via email to bibleqa3abn.tv.
TV. That's bible QA3BN.tv.
Or if you want to text us those
questions, you can text us to
6182283975.
That's 6182283975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions in that way at 3abn_official.
3ABN official.
All right, Pastor James got a long
question for you for your first one.
Here we go.
I've recently been having anxiety
attacks concerning the second coming,
and I'm convinced that Jesus is coming
within this presidency. I know that no
man knoweth the day nor hour, and lean
not unto not on your own understanding.
For clarity, what events will lead up to
the National Sunday Law? Are we told in
the Bible whether it will happen
gradually or suddenly? What does having
an American pope mean for these end
times? That's from Joshua who emailed
that to us. Thank you, Joshua. That's a
great question. I think it would apply
to a lot of people today. When we look
at what's happening in our world, in our
country, we can see that there's a lot
for us to be concerned about. And yet
the Bible tells us that we need to be at
peace that God has told us to be of good
cheer. Amen. And and so how do we um
navigate this? I'd like to answer your
questions because it's it's a complex
question. I'd like to answer it in two
parts. Uh first of all, since there's a
lot to it, we want to talk about the
significance of an American pope. And
when we look at the idea of an American
pope in relationship to all of the other
signs that God has given us, the idea of
an American pope is almost
insignificant. It's not really a major
issue in the context of biblical signs.
Now, it may be a major issue for a lot
of people. They may be thinking, "Oh, an
American pope. This is huge." But when
you look at the biblical signs, it
doesn't play a a large part of what God
has told us to be looking for in these
last days. Uh number two according to
the Bible the you asked about is it
going to be sudden or is it going to be
gradual according to the Bible to Bible
prophecy it is both gradual that is what
is happening right now is very gradual
the progression to the fulfillment of
prophecy is very gradual it's been
happening over at least all the decades
that I've been studying Bible prophecy
there's been a gradual moving toward
this end goal but it's also something
that happens suddenly the final
movements are going to be sudden
movements ments and we're going to look
at a few Bible texts that will help us
to understand this. The first place I
want you to look is in Matthew chapter
24. Matthew 24 is an outline of the
signs that Jesus warned us about. And
one of the things that is important for
us to understand in Matthew chapter 24
is that there's going to be a lot of
deception in the last days and a lot of
misunderstanding. And Jesus gives us
this warning in Matthew 24:es
4 and 5. He also mentions it in verse 11
and then again in verses 23 and 24. He
says it's going to be false Christ. It's
the most repeated sign of all the signs
in Matthew 24. But it's not the most
misunderstood.
The most misunderstood sign is actually
in verse 14. A lot of people quote this
verse Matthew 24:14 this way. And this
gospel of the kingdom will be preached
in all the world and then shall the end
come. I hear that quoted that way many
times. But the a the verse actually says
this, "And this gospel of the kingdom
shall be preached in all the world for a
witness unto all nations, and then shall
the end come."
>> Now, if you were to put all of the signs
in Matthew 24 on one side of a scale,
and you were to take this sign, this one
sign, and put it on the other side of
the scale, it would tip the scale. Jesus
says, "When this sign is fulfilled, he's
coming back." So more important than an
American pope is the witness of the
gospel. And the witness of the gospel
depends not on the pope, not on the
Sunday law, not on the US president or
the legislation of laws that violate our
conscience. The this sign depends on
God's people. In other words, according
to second Peter chapter 3 and:12, we
have the power to hasten the coming of
Christ by allowing the mystery of God to
be fulfilled in us, which is the hope of
glory. When that mystery of God is
fulfilled in us, and this is talked
about in Revelation 10 uh and verse 7
specifically, it talks about the fact
that there's not going to be any more
time prophecies that are going to
indicate the closeness of Christ coming.
All the time prophecies have been
fulfilled. the 2300, the 1290, the 1260,
the 13:35. All these time elements have
been fulfilled. Now, we're looking for
the mystery of God to be finished.
Christ in us, the hope of glory.
Colossians 1:26. When that is finished,
when God's people are ready, then God
can wrap this up because then there's
going to be a witness to the gospel. How
important is the witness? The word
actually comes from a Greek word which
means martyr. Revelation 12 and verse 11
talks about God's people who overcome by
the blood of the lamb by the word of
their testimony and they love not their
lives unto the death. This is vital when
we have the gospel preached as a
witness. When people live the gospel to
the point where they are selfless in
their characters and their attitude when
they are focused on Christ's glory,
God's glory and no one else's glory, God
can finish this up because then we have
a contrast. Then we have uh a test group
if you will, right? We have a group of
people who can be seen as keeping the
commandments of God and having the faith
of Jesus in the context of the mark of
the beast being forced enforced upon all
the world. People are going to need to
see a witness in order for them to make
an important decision, an eternal
decision as to whether they're going to
worship the beast and receive his mark
or whether they're going to worship God
and be sealed with the seal of God. So
please don't be anxious. God tells us in
John 14 verse uh 27 and John 16 verse33
don't let your heart be troubled be have
peace be of good cheer.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you sir. Thank you
very much for your answer.
>> All right, Sister Shelley. Here's your
first question.
I live alone and therefore pray alone.
Does God still hear me and remain
present with me? That's from Zelia in
South Africa who emailed that to us.
>> Zelia. Yes, he does.
And I think your question is stemming
from Matthew 18:20 where Jesus said,
"Where two or three are gathered
together in my name, there I am in the
midst of them." This verse is often
quoted to describe this precious truth
that Jesus is present with believers who
gather for worship or prayer. But it's
certainly true. But we have to look at
the surrounding verses Matthew 18
15-20 to understand its full context
which deals with church discipline,
reconciliation
and unity among believers. So Jesus is
confirming his divine authority and his
spiritual presence that will guide and
unite the church the decisions of his
followers who are gathered to seek his
will. He is not placing a limitation on
his presence. He lives in his believers
by faith. it. We are told this in
Ephesians 3 that the Holy as the Holy
Spirit indwells as Christ lives in our
hearts by faith and we're never truly
alone.
>> Jesus said, "Lo, I am with you always,
even to the end of the world." That's
Matthew 8 uh 28. Amen. Matthew 28:20.
Scripture never implies that a solitary
prayer is any less powerful or that God
is absent from the individual who is
seeking him in faith. So God's presence
is not dependent upon how many people
are praying together. It depends on his
covenant love with you.
>> Scripture is clear that God meets with
individuals in prayer. Think about
Daniel praying in Babylon as he prayed
alone. Elijah on Mount Carmel. Think
about the three Hebrew worthies they
were praying to or Daniel was praying
there or Jesus himself praying alone. In
Luke 5:16,
it says that Jesus withdrew into the
wilderness and prayed. So solitary
prayer is precious to God. He's with you
in that quiet place. You know, in
Matthew 6:6, he said, "Go into your
closet. Open I mean, close the doors and
be in that quiet place." And the Lord is
there with you in that quiet place. He's
listening to you
>> as you approach his throne of grace.
Approach as his child. You are his
child. Speak to him as a friend.
You know, we are when we pray, we are
speaking to a loving heart.
>> Amen.
>> A heart that knows us better than we
know oursel. He knows every
thing about our lives and our needs.
We're never praying to an empty void.
We're conversing with our creator
himself.
>> Amen.
>> And you know what? He bends low to
listen. In Revelation 8:3 and4, it says
that our prayers ascend like incense
before his throne. And uh Romans 8:26
says the Holy Spirit interceds for us
with groanings that cannot be otherred.
So whether you're praying in a group or
praying in solitude, his presence
surrounds you. His spirit fills you and
his ear is always inclined toward you.
Dear
Zelia, Zelia, it's a beautiful name. God
hears you and he answers.
>> Amen. Amen. I love a prayer answering
God.
>> Amen.
>> All right, Pastor James, here's your
second question.
Can you please help me follow and
understand David's thought process in
Psalms 139-
24?
I read this. But then in Matthew 5:44,
Jesus tells us to love our enemies. I
know we've been taught that the Bible
doesn't contradict itself. So what am I
missing here? How does Psalms 139-
24 fit with Jesus command to love our
enemies in Matthew chapter 5 verse 44?
And that question was texted to us.
Great question. Let's just take a look
here because there does seem to be a
contradiction. David is in Psalm 139.
David is actually
uh processing his thoughts and feelings
with God. And we find this all through
the Psalms. It's a beautiful picture of
how we can learn to process our thoughts
and feelings, especially if they're
negative feelings with God so that we
don't process them and act them out
toward other people.
>> Psalm 139, let's just start with verse
39. David says, "Surely thou wilt slay
the wicked, oh God. Depart from me,
therefore, ye bloody men, for they speak
against thee wickedly, and thine enemies
take thy name in vain. Do not I hate
them, oh Lord, that hate thee, and am I
not grieved with those that rise up
against thee? I hate them with perfect
hatred. I count them my enemies. Search
me, oh God, and know my heart. Try me
and know my thoughts, and see if there
be any wicked way in me, and lead me in
the way everlasting.
would that we would pray the way David
just prayed because it's obvious in our
actions and in our thoughts that we have
ought with people and many times we just
stuff it or sometimes we talk to other
people. David takes it to God. He's
saying you know I'm having these
thoughts and I'm having these feelings
and I imagine that David understands the
principle that Jesus talks about in
Matthew 5 and verse 44 where he says
that we should love our enemies and pray
for those that despitefully use us.
David was a man after God's own heart.
And he understood this. He understood
the principles of love, but he's
struggling with it. I hate those that
hate you. I just want you to slay them
and take them out. And of course, David
could have been talking about Saul, for
example, because Saul was in apostasy.
He was uh leading the whole nation away
from God. He even at one point was
trying to kill David and even tried to
kill his son Jonathan. And we see uh
David agonizing about Saul, agonizing
about wickedness and giving it to God.
But notice this.
When David actually confronts Saul, I
should say when he has opportunity to
confront Saul or to take Saul out in a
cave and in his campsite two different
occasions, he doesn't do it.
>> He doesn't put forth his hand against
the Lord's anointed. Now, I think one of
the reasons for this is because David
has learned to process his anger with
God and give it to God and let God fill
him with the Holy Spirit so that he can
actually love his enemies and pray for
those that despitefully use him and of
course hate God. We see this all through
the Psalms. I'm going to give you one
example. It's found in Psalm 55. It's an
outline that I call help. Help P. Psalm
55 or 54, excuse me. Psalm 54. This is
the shortest one we can find. And the
acronym stands for H. Help me Lord. So
in verse one, save me, oh God, by thy
name. Judge me um by thy strength. So
he's asking God to save him. Hear my
prayer. Verse two, oh God, give ear to
my word, the words of my mouth. That's
the H part. Then there's the E part.
That's explain. Verse three, for
strangers are wisen up against me and
oppressors seek after my soul. They have
not set God before them. See law. So
that's the E. Explain. He explains the
situation. Ask God for help. Explains a
situation. Then L. He lets out his
anger. Behold, God is my helper. The
Lord is with them that uphold my soul.
He shall reward evil unto my enemies.
Cut them off in your truth. In other
words, he just wants to, oh, let out his
anger. Just cut him off, Lord. Cut them
off. And then Praise God. He finishes up
by praising God. Verse six. I will
freely sacrifice unto thee. I will
praise thy name, oh Lord God, for it is
good.
This is how David prayed and this is
what led him to be merciful. He was able
to process his anger to God about people
so that he could be loving and be kind,
turn the other cheek and pray for those
that despitefully used him. And when
Saul died, who was trying to kill David,
when Saul was killed, David wept for him
and they were not crocodile tears. The
Bible gives us the same outline in the
book of Ephesians in the New Testament.
Ephesians chapter 4 and verse 26. It
says, "Be angry and sin not. Don't let
the sun go down on your wrath." So,
what's happening there in Psalm 139 is
that David is processing his anger with
God. You'll see it all through the
Psalms, just like we're encouraged to do
here in Ephesians 4:26. Be angry before
you go to bed. Process your anger. If
you've had any bad experiences through
the day, give them to God and then you
won't sin. And do this before the sun
goes down on your wrath because God
wants to fill that vacancy that's made
when you give him your anger with his
spirit of peace and love and goodwill.
And perhaps before you even lay down to
sleep, you can pray for those enemies
that you just uh that you just process
to God uh just a few seconds before.
>> That's right.
>> Amen. Man, that was really good. I
haven't thought about it like that
before. Thank you for sharing it.
>> Good.
>> All right, Shelley, here's your next
question. When does faith become
presumption?
Can you please give distinct
characteristics of the two and cite
Bible texts? That's from Jojo in Arizona
who texted that to us. Jojo, I'm going
to tell you I got a sermon on this, but
uh I can I can only give you this much
of it today, but I am going to do a
sermon that great question. I'm going to
treat this as two questions. What is
faith? What is presumption? And I just
want to start by saying both faith and
presumption involve belief and
expectation. But their foundation, their
motivation are completely different.
Faith trusts what God has said. It
submits to his will and obeys the
conditions of the word with acts of
humility and dependence upon God. And it
awaits God's timing. Presumption is the
devil's counterfeit of faith.
>> Presumption takes God's promises out of
context. It twists the word, seeks to
control the outcome. acts from
self-confidence and pride and it rushes
ahead of God's timing.
You know what presumption demands
instant proof.
>> So let's look at what is faith. What is
presumption?
>> Faith is rooted in God's word and in his
will. We have to have confidence that
what God has actually said is the truth.
It's he his covenant promises that he
has made to us are part of his covenant.
Romans 10:17 says, "Faith comes by
hearing and hearing by the word of God."
So you can't have faith in God apart
from the word of God. Proverbs 3:5 and 6
says, "Trust in the Lord with all of
your heart. Lean not on your own
understanding."
If you're not leaning on your
understanding, whose are you leaning on?
>> The what? The word of God says and it
goes on to say in all of your ways
acknowledge him. He will direct your
your path. So faith trusts that is the
foundation of faith is trusting in God.
And we trust in his character. And we
believe that everything that he is doing
is for our eternal benefit. Hebrews 11
1-6 says, "Faith is the substance of
things hoped for." It's the title deed.
That's what that word substance is. It's
the title D. And it goes on in verse six
to say without faith it is impossible to
please God because we have to believe
that he is and he rewards those who
earnestly diligently seek him. So faith
rests on his promises and it moves in
harmony with the conditions of the word.
James 21:17 says, "Faith without works
is dead." Faith without works, without
obedience is still born. James 14 and
verse 15, Jesus said, "If you love me,
keep my commandments." So faith always
includes obedience and submission to
God's will. Just as Jesus said in the
garden, Luke 22:42,
"Not my will, but yours be done." In
Genesis 22, Abraham believed and acted.
Daniel 3, the three Hebrews trusted and
stood firm. Faith says, "God said it, I
will do it."
>> But faith waits on God's timing. Psalm
37:5 says, "Commit your way to the Lord.
Trust also in him. He shall bring it to
pass. Psalm 27:14.
Wait on the word, Lord. Be of good
courage. He shall strengthen your heart.
Wait, I say on the Lord. So faith leads
to humility and peace. Micah 6:8. He has
shown you, oh man, what is good, what
does the Lord require of you? But to do
justly, to love mercely, mercy, and to
walk humbly with your God. The
difference of presumption. Let's look at
that. Presumption is self-confidence.
It's dressed in religious language. It's
rooted in vain imaginations. It takes
promises out of context. It twists God's
word. It makes,
how can I say this? It makes a demand
that tests God rather than trusting God.
In Matthew 45 5-7, Satan tempted Jesus
to jump from the temple. He says in
verse 6, "If you're the son of God,
throw yourself down. For it is written,
he shall give his angels charge over
you, and in their hands they shall bear
you up, lest you dash your foot against
a stone." Is that scripture? Absolutely,
it's scripture. That's Psalm 91:11-12.
Satan knows scripture. But he's taking
the promise, a precious promise of God
that we should trust in him and he's
twisting it in a manner that leaves out
the rest of God's the rest of scripture
and what God has to say. So Jesus
answers him with another scripture in
Matthew 5:7. He said, "It is written
again." Yeah, that's written, but it is
written again. You shall not tempt the
Lord your God. Jesus refused to test
God's promises. And that's what some
people do. Lord, you you know, if you
don't heal me, then I'm not going to
believe in you anymore. So, they uh
presumption is rooted in self-will. It
claims the promise, ignores the
condition. And we know what Jeremiah
17:9 says that our heart is deceitful
above all things. presumption acts as we
desire. Taking what we want and
attaching God's name to it, saying, "My
will be done and God will bless it."
Presumption imitates faith. It expects
God's blessings while disregarding his
will, refusing submission and obedience,
often excusing our own transgressions
rather than meeting God's conditions to
receive the promise. Numbers 14:40-45
Israel went to battle after God said not
to and they this was presumption and
they were defeated. Psalm 19:13 David
prayed keep back your servant from
presumptuous sins. 1st Samuel 13 8-14 we
see where King Saul makes a sacrifice
and he wasn't as the king. He was not
anointed to offer a sacrifice, but he
didn't want to wait for Samuel the
prophet. And what does Samuel say in
First Samuel 15:22-23?
When Samuel so shows up, he tells Saul,
man, you you messed up. You were
presumptuous. And he says to obey is
better than sacrifice. So presumption
leads to defeat. It leads to spiritual
blindness. Listen to this. Second Peter
2:10. Paul uh Paul or Peter is talking
about those who walk according to the
flesh in lust of uncleanness, despising
authority. He said they are
presumptuous,
self-willed. They're defiant. They're
arrogant. They're obstinate. They're
determined to have their own way. So
true faith honors God, trusting his
promise, keeping his commands.
presumption dishonors God by demanding
blessings without obedience. And our
safest path to walk the Christian walk
is to walk in total humble dependence
upon our God.
>> Amen. Amen. Thank you, Shel.
>> Amen.
>> All right, Pastor Jame, I've got your
next question, but let me remind our
viewers how they can participate. Well,
you can do so one of three ways. You can
send us your questions via email to
bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bibleqa3abn.tv.
And then for those you want to text us,
you can text us to 618-2283975.
That's 618228-3975.
And then for those of you who are on
Instagram, you can send us your
questions at 3ABN official at
3abn_official.
All right, Pastor James, here's your
next question.
The woman went into the wilderness after
she gave birth to the male child in
Revelation 12:5.
Who is the they in verse 6 that should
feed her? Is she the same woman in
Revelation 17:es 1-6 and Revelation 18?
That's from Sandra in Alabama who texted
that to us.
Great question, Sandra. Thank you so
much. Let's let's look at a two-part
answer here. Let's start with the they
uh in the verse. Um the they is God. Uh
the word is actually added in verse six.
The verse in the Greek actually reads to
pl to a place of God. Feed her there
1260 days. Uh there's no Greek support
for the addition of the word they. But
maybe they added it because you know in
the context it's talking about God,
heaven, whatever the provision is that
God makes for the woman. It's coming
from God. It's not coming from any other
source except perhaps the wilderness
itself. But again, that's God's
provision. Now, we know this because
verse 14 of Revelation 12 repeats the
same chapter idea, the same point of the
woman fleeing into the wilderness, but
only with a little bit of a different
emphasis. In verse 14, it basically says
that the woman, let's just read it now,
is given two wings of a great eagle that
she might fly into the wilderness into
her place where she is nourished for a
time and times and half a time from the
face of the serpent. So the woman flies
into the same wilderness during the same
time, the same prophetic period, but
notice there's no they in that verse.
She's nourished and we know she was
nourished of God. So finally we want to
look at this question about the woman of
revelation 17 and 18 being the same
woman of revelation chapter 12. Now
there are several reasons why this is
not possible. All right. First of all
the two women exist simultaneously. That
is during the 42-month period. During
the dark ages, during the 1260, the 42
months, you have the woman, the woman
that is clothed in the sun and standing
on the moon with crown of 12 stars.
She's fleeing into the wilderness. And
in that same time, you have the other
woman of Revelation 17 who is
persecuting the woman that's fleeing
into the wilderness. So, both women are
existing simultaneously. They can't be
the same woman. The other thing we need
to look at here is that Revelation, the
Revelation 12 woman is pictured as
standing on the moon clothed with the
sun and has a remnant who keep the
commandments of God and have the
testimony of Jesus. The Revelation 17
woman sits on waters and on the beast.
So the Revelation 12 woman standing on
the moon represents that she's standing
on the word of God. We're told in Psalm
119 105 that thy word is a lamp to my
feet and a light to my path. Her being
clothed with the sun represents her
being clothed with the righteousness of
Jesus Christ, trusting in the merits of
Jesus for salvation. And Jesus is the
son of righteous righteousness in Micah
4:2.
The other woman sits on many waters. Now
the waters represent peoples and nations
and multitudes and tongues. Revelation
17:15.
That woman also sits on a beast which
represents civil support for what she
believes and the doctrines she teaches.
So you have one woman that's standing on
the word of God and is trusting in
Christ's merits and another woman that's
looking for the support of the majority
of people in this world as well as
looking for civil support. Completely
different support systems for these two
women. Now, another thing we want to
look at is that the Revelation 12 woman
actually marries Jesus in Revelation 19.
The Revelation 17 woman is completely
unfaithful to Jesus. She is a harlot.
So, you've got two different destinies
for these two women. Now we want to look
a little further here and just identify
this woman in verses 1-5 because we see
there that this woman is actually the
one that gives birth to a manchild i.e.
Jesus who is caught up to God and to his
throne. So the woman in Revelation 12
1-5 actually represents the Jewish
church from which Jesus came and then in
verse 6 it transitions to the Christian
church and that church flees into the
wilderness for the 1260year prophetic
period and after she comes out of the
wilderness the remnant of that woman
keeps the commandments of God and has
the testimony of Jesus. The Revelation
17 woman does not keep the commandments
of God. She is unfaithful to God's
commandments. Actually changing two of
them. One is eliminated. The second
commandment forbidding the worship of
idols. And the fourth commandment is
changed from Sabbath to Sunday, from the
seventh day Sabbath, Saturday to Sunday.
So you have this woman in Revelation 17
identified as a harlot. And she's the
mother of harlots, right? She has
daughters. We understand that to be
those who follow her doctrines or drink
of the wine of her teachings. So there's
no way these two women can be the same.
They are in in exact opposition to each
other. One persecuting the other and one
being faithful to God. One standing on
God's word, being clothed with Christ's
righteousness, the other getting it
support from the peoples and nations and
multitudes of this world and civil uh
governments.
>> Amen.
>> Amen. Very thorough answer. Thank you,
sir.
All right, Sister Shelley, here's your
next question. When Moses went to
Jethro, his father-in-law, before
leading Israel, and later returned to
meet his family after the deliverance,
did he go 40 years without seeing them
or were there frequent visits during
that time? That's from Joseph in Kenya
who emailed that question.
>> Okay, Joseph. Um, Exodus 4:18-20.
Before Moses had he'd already spent the
40 years on the back side of the desert,
he married Zapora. He had two sons.
Before he returned to Egypt, he went to
Jethro, his father-in-law, to ask for
his permission. Then he took Zapora and
his two sons. But somewhere along the
way, Zapora ended up circumcising their
son. That's Exodus 4:24- 26. And
afterwards, Moses apparently sent her
back to her father's house in Midian.
Scripture doesn't say that directly, but
the next time we hear of Moses' families
in Exodus 18 1-6.
And Exodus 18:2 says Moses had Moses had
sent her back. Verse 5 says Jethro was
now returning Zapora and the two sons of
Moses to him and they went out. He
Jethro brought them to the place um as
as to the place where they were camping
in Rifodim and uh this was the fourth
stop that Israel had made after the
exodus. They went first they stopped
they encamped at Marra where the waters
were busy bitter they camped at Alim
where there was dates the wilderness of
scene where they had the test of the
mana and their faithfulness to the
Sabbath. And then their fourth
encampment was Refodm and Refodm
was close. It was just a day's journey
from Mount Si. It was close to Jethro's
house. And in Exodus 19:12, it says in
the third month, they departed Refodm
and arrived at Mount Si. So this means
that Moses was separated from his family
during the time of the Exodus before the
plagues and then until after the
crossing of the Red Sea and these
several months that they spent encamped.
But um the time frame, the deliverance
of Israel only took a few months, not 40
years on the Exodus journey, the 40
years refers to Israel's later
wilderness wandering after the rebellion
at Kadesh Barnea in Numbers 14. So Moses
was united with his family early in the
wilderness journey long before the 40
years began.
>> Amen. Thank you, sister. All right,
Pastor James, here's your next question.
Do all 66 books of the Bible have pro
prophetic content? I know there are
different types of prophecies, but it
seems that all of them contain some
element of prophecy. That's from an in
Pennsylvania who texted that question to
us.
>> Thank you, Ann Pennsylvania. I
appreciate your questions. uh you are
pretty consistent sending to us and it's
really great to to have them. Uh from
what I've understood, what I've studied,
yes, most of the books of the Bible do
actually have prophetic content, but uh
and some of it's kind of veiled. You
know, you don't always see the the
prophetic dynamic in there. For example,
you can even read uh Ephesians talks
about uh and Colossians talks about the
mystery of God being finished. That's
definitely connected to the book of
Revelation. And in fact, if you go to
the book of Revelation, kind of work out
of the book of Revelation, it's going to
connect you to most of the books of the
Bible. I've done a lot of study in the
book of Revelation. So, it's really
helped me to see these other books and
how they're connected to prophecy. Uh
not directly necessarily in that they're
prophetic, but in that they help unlock
prophecy. If I could just clarify that.
But there are some books that don't have
clear prophetic content. Um, I'm just
going to give you two because I don't
know if others uh would be added to that
and maybe my sister Shelley can help
with that, but I'd say Fleiman and Third
John do not have any prophetic content
that I've been able to find.
>> Okay. Okay. Thank you, sir. All right,
Sister Shelley, here's your question.
Next question. Could you please explain
the differences between body, spirit,
and soul? What happens to each when we
die? That's from Mike in Michigan who
emailed that to us.
>> Mike, it's a precious question. I hope
you've got a pen and paper because I'm
going to give you a number of scripture
references. Genesis 2:7 says, "The Lord
formed man of the dust of the ground."
That's the body. And breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life. That's the
spirit. It's ruach in the Hebrew and it
can mean uh breath uh wind spirit. So
this is when it's talking about he
breathed this is the divine energy that
spark of life that animated the body and
then it says and man became a living
soul. God didn't give man a soul. It is
the union of the body and the breath of
life that spirit that creates a living
individual. So at death, you've got just
the reverse formula. Ecclesiastes 12 and
verse 7. Ecclesiastes 12:7.
Then shall the dust, that's the body,
return to the earth as it was. And the
spirit, the ruach, that's again the same
word, shall return unto God who gave it.
So spirit, ru is the same word for
breath. Ruach. And then Ecclesiasters
3:19 and 20 it says what happens to the
sons of men hap also happens to animals
one thing befalls them as one dies so
dies the other surely they all have one
breath what's the ruach the spirit the
breath of life man has no advantage over
the animals for all is vanity all go to
one place all are from the dust and all
return to the dust so he's talking about
the body let's break that Now the body
decays and returns to dust. When we die,
Genesis 3:19, God told them, "In the
sweat of your face, you shall eat bread
till you return to the ground. For out
of it you are taken, for dust you are,
and to dust you shall return." What
happens to the spirit? The breath of
life. Remember this is not a conscious
being.
The breath of life is that energy that
God breathed into us that animates us
and it returns to God. Job 27 and verse
three says as long as my breath ruach as
long as my breath is in me and the
breath the spirit that it says the
breath of God in my nostrils. Same word
for spirit and the spirit of God is in
my nostrils. No, it's ruach. And Psalm
146:4 said, "His spirit, the Ru departs.
He returns to his earth. In that very
day, his plans perish."
>> So we return
as Ecclesiastes 12:7 says, "The spirit
returns to God." Now, what about the
soul, the living person? The soul ceases
to exist because the combination of body
and spirit no longer exists. So the soul
doesn't exist apart
from the union of the body and the
breath of life, the spirit. That's what
creates a living soul. Think of it as a
light bulb.
>> Your body is like the bulb. Your spirit
or breath is like the electricity in the
bulb. And the soul is the light that is
produced when those two are joined. But
at death, the light goes out.
>> And God holds the power to turn it back
on at the resurrection. Let you ask
about what happens when we die. The
Bible teaches that death is asleep. It's
not a continuation of conscious life.
Here's some scriptures. Ecclesiastes 9:5
says, "The dead know nothing." Psalm
146:4.
His breath, his spirit departs. He
returns to the earth, and in that very
day his thoughts perish. John 11 11-14,
Jesus said, "Our friend Lazarus sleeps,
and I'm going that I may wake him out of
his sleep." They thought Laziples
thought Lazarus was resting and would
get well. And Jesus explained in verse
14, he said clearly to them, Lazarus is
dead. So the the Bible refers to death
as an unconscious sleep until the
resurrection. And in John 5:28-29,
Jesus said all who are in their graves
will hear my voice. The righteous come
up in the first resurrection. Jesus said
they will rise to the resurrection of
life and the evil to the resurrection of
condemnation. So when that first
resurrection happens, that's what the
second coming. And 1 Thessalonians 4:16
says that the Lord himself will descend
from heaven with a shout and the dead in
Christ will li rise first. So God
restores our lifegiving breath and he
gives us a glorified body and that's
when immortality
is bestowed to mankind. Right now first
Timothy 6:16 says God alone is immortal.
No man is immortal. There's no such
thing as an immortal soul
>> because a soul is a living individual.
If you're dead, you're dead. But in 1
Corinthians 15:51-54,
at the second coming, he says that this
corruptible puts on incorruption. This
mortal will put on immortality in the
blink of an eye. And until then, we rest
in the dead,
>> in the grave, unconscious, awaiting the
resurrection.
>> Amen. Thank you, Shel. A lot of people
have questions about what happens when
you die, and this is a great biblical
answer. Appreciate that. All right,
Pastor James, here's your last question.
Can you please explain Ezekiel chapter
9? That's from Gabriel, who sent that to
us via chat on our website.
>> Thank you, Gabriel. Ezekiel chapter 9.
It's probably better understood if you
start in Ezekiel chapter 8. So, we'll do
that. We'll start in Ezekiel chapter 8
and just ignore the chapter division.
We'll start in verse 15 of Ezekiel 8.
The then said he that is the Lord unto
me, hast thou seen this, oh son of man,
turn thee yet again, and thou shalt see
greater abominations than these? And
then verse 16 of he of Ezekiel chapter
8. And he brought me into the inner
court of the Lord's house. And behold,
at the door of the temple of the Lord,
between the porch and the altar, were
about five and 20 men with their backs
toward the temple of the Lord, and their
faces toward the east. And they
worshiped the sun toward the east.
That's Sunday worship. We see that in
Revelation 13 as part of that mark of
the beast conflict that we're going to
be facing in the end of time. Verse 17
of chapter 8. Then he said unto me,
"Hast thou seen this, oh son of man? Is
it a light thing to the house of Judah
that they commit the abominations with
which they commit here? For they have
filled the land with violence and have
returned to provoke me to anger. And lo,
they put the branch to their nose.
Therefore, verse 18, I will also deal in
f in fury.
My eye shall not spare, neither shall I
have pity. And though they cry in mine
ears with a loud voice, yet I will not
hear them. Now chapter 9 verse1 he cried
also in my hearing saying uh in mine
ears with a loud voice saying cause them
that have charge over the city to draw
near even every man with his destroying
weapon in his hands. So now we're
looking at a parallel to the seven last
plagues in Revelation chapters 15 and 16
verse 2. And behold, six men came from
the way of the higher gate, which lies
toward the north, every man a slaughter
weapon in his hand, and one man among
them was clothed with linen with a
rider's inkorn by his side. And they
went in and stood beside the brazen
altar. Verse three, the glory of the
Lord God of Israel was gone up from the
cherub, whereupon he was, to the
threshold of the house, and he called to
the man clothed with linen, which had
the writer's incorn by his side. Verse
four. And the Lord said unto him, "Go
through the midst of the city, through
the midst of Jerusalem, that is the
church, and mark set a mark upon the
foreheads of the men that sigh and cry
for all the abominations that be done in
the midst thereof." This is the sealing
time. This is the time when God's people
who are sign and crying for the
abominations done in the church and in
the land are going to be sealed with the
seal of God. We know that that is
connected with the Sabbath because the
word mark here is also used in Exodus
20:es 8-11. The word remember also means
to mark. Remember the Sabbath day. Mark
the Sabbath day to keep it holy. So
there's a direct connection here between
the Sabbath which is sealed in us
through the Holy Spirit. Of course,
God's seal being God himself, the Holy
Spirit himself is the one who seals us,
and the law of God, including the
Sabbath, being a transcript of God's
character. So, they are one in the same.
And to the others, verse 5, he said, "In
my hearing, go after them through the
city and smite. Let not your eyes spare,
neither have pity slay utterly old and
young." Verse six, maids and little
children, women, but come not near any
man upon whom is the mark. And they
begin at my sanctuary. and and begin at
my sanctuary. And they began at the
ancient men which were before the house.
So this is the time when probation
closes when God has no more mercy. The
seven last plagues are the last plagues
because there's no they're not mingled
with mercy. And God begins at his house.
That is those who profess faith in
Christ. And especially the ancient men,
that is the ministers and the pastors
who have misled the people are going to
be first to feel the wrath of God when
these seven last plagues when these
destroying angels uh go forth after
God's people are sealed. Now God's
people are sealed. They're protected.
They are not in uh affected by these
seven last plagues of these destroying
angels. And and verse seven, and he said
unto them, despile the house and fill
the courts with the slain. Go forth. and
they went forth and slew in the city.
So, as the uh story finishes, as the
chapter finishes here, Ezekiel says,
"Aren't you going to have any mercy?
Can't you have any pity?" And of course,
this is a plea from the heart of a human
who's been touched by the grace and
mercy of God. And this is the plea we
have. We want to have right now. We're
asking God, we're praying for God to
hold back those four winds in this Bible
prophecy that's about to be fulfilled in
Revelation chapter 13. And so Ezekiel
8:9 parallel Revelation chapter 13 and
14 and then 15 and 16. We're to pray God
hold back those winds so that we can we
can proclaim the everlasting gospel, the
three angels message, warning against
receiving the mark, warning against
worshiping the beast and receiving the
mark of the beast and and calling people
to remember the Sabbath day to mark the
Sabbath day and be sealed with that
Sabbath truth sealed into the Holy
Spirit so they cannot be moved.
>> Amen.
>> Wonderful. Wonderful. I see we have just
an extra minute. Could I just add
something about what happens when we
die? Because you mentioned that.
>> We talked about the first resurrection,
but we didn't talk about the second
resurrection. This is the resurrection
to condemnation. And it happens a
thousand years later according to
Revelation 20 and verse 5. Says the rest
of the dead after the first resurrection
did not live again until the thousand
years were finished. And then in
Revelation 2011 through13, there's a
great white throne judgment. And what's
it says is that all who are uh in this
great white throne judgment, these
people, they're going to be thrown into
the lake of fire and perish in the
second death. There is a second death.
Let me give you four scriptures that you
need to look up if you don't know that
that is going to happen. Revelation 20
verses 14- 15, Revelation 21,
Revelation 20 verse 6, Revelation 21:8,
and Hebrews 9:27 says, "It's appointed
for all men to die once, but after that
the judgment."
>> Amen. Thank you, Sister Shelley. All
right, we're going to take a short
break. We'll be right back.
>> If you're enjoying our 3ABN Bible Q&A,
then tell your friends. Each Monday,
we'll bring you a fresh program
answering the Bible questions you send
us using God's Holy Word to shed light
on those texts that seem difficult to
understand. To have your questions
answered on a future program, just email
them to us at bibleqa3abn.tv.
That's bible qa3abn.tv.
You may also text your questions to
618-2283975.
That's 618-2283975.
Be sure to include your name and where
you live and then watch through Bible
Q&A for answers from God's word.
>> Our time is almost up, but let's get
some final thoughts from our panelists.
I have a final thought on faith and that
is this faith is a gift from God. It is
the power of God. We are filled with the
Holy Spirit. First Peter 1 uh 5-8 says
we are kept by the power of God through
faith for salvation ready to be revealed
in the last time. It brings joy even
when we have trials.
>> Amen. Amen. Brother James,
>> just want to go back to that question
about the anxiety attacks and the
presidency and all of the prophecies.
John chap 16 verse 33. These things I
have spoken unto you that in me you
might have peace. In the world you shall
have tribulation, but be of good cheer.
I have overcome the world. It's very
important for us to be in Christ and not
in the world. Anxiety comes from being
in the world inundated with perhaps the
news or the media or everything that's
happening in the world. But peace comes
from being in Christ and following the
lamb wherever he goes. In fact,
Revelation 14:4 is our instruction for
the mark of the beast crisis. Follow the
lamb wherever he goes and you will have
that peace.
>> Amen. Amen. Well, thank you very much
for joining us, brother and sister. And
thank you for joining us. Let me leave
you with this fun scripture song.
And the Lord, he is the one who goes
before you. He will be with you. He will
not leave you nor forsake you. Do not
fear nor be dismayed. Deuteronomy 31
verse8. Thanks for joining us. Tune in
next time. God bless.